dig site sheer rock walls surround this  militia mining facility creating a  bloody brown dwarf Titan skirmishes  erupted amongst the industrial  processing buildings while pilots used  the terrain to gain the high ground of  the massive rocks or  export reminiscent of the goldrush  boomtowns from centuries earlier the  close quarters of this militia  settlement allow pilots to use football  runs to gain speed and height to engage  enemies from above while Titans use  choke points and steep inclines to  control the battlefield below  Haven an exclusive beach resort built to  cater to the wealthy elite of the  frontier home to hotel skyscrapers art  galleries and luxury restaurants these  large interiors encourage discreet pilot  only fire fights while Titans hold down  strategic locations on the surrounding  beach and roadway